EVERYBODY.
TUCKER IS UP NEXT FROM
WASHINGTON.
♪
>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING AND
WELCOME TO "TUCKER CARLSON
TONIGHT."
LEADERS ON BOTH SIDES OF THE
AISLE IN CONGRESS IN THE
MEDIA AND OUR INTELLIGENCE
SERVICES AND VIRTUALLY EVERY
OVERFUNDED THINK TANK IN
WASHINGTON HAVE SUDDENLY
ALIGNED TONIGHT ON A SINGLE
POINT OF AGREEMENT.
AMERICA MUST GO TO WAR IN
SYRIA IMMEDIATELY.
BASHAR AL ASSAD CANNOT
CONTINUE TO LEAD THAT
COUNTRY.
HE MUST BE OVERTHROWN.
ASSAD IS AN EVIL MAN, THEY
TELL US, HIS LATEST CRIME IS
A CHLORINE GAS ATTACK
CARRIED OUT OVER THE WEEKEND
BY HIS FORCES AGAINST A
REBEL HELD SUBURB OF DAMAS
KING CAN YOU SAY.
HIS POISON GAS SUFFOCATED
CHILDREN.
PICTURES OF THE AFTERMATH OF
THAT ARE ALL OVER THE
INTERNET AND THEY ARE
HORRIFYING.
ASSAD IS A MONSTER.
THAT'S THE OFFICIAL STORY.
ALMOST EVERYONE IN POWER
CLAIMS TO BELIEVE IT.
THE PUSH TO WAR IN SYRIA, BY
THE WAY HAS UNITED
POLITICIANS HAVE BOTH SIDES.
LINDSEY GRAHAM AND HOWARD
DEAN TYPICALLY AGREE ON VERY
LITTLE.
NOT MUCH AT ALL.
BUT TODAY THEY ARE BOTH
CALLING FOR WAR IN SYRIA.
GRAHAM IS GHANELDING MASSIVE
ATTACKS ON THE SYRIAN
MILITARY, DEAN IS GOING EVEN
FURTHER THAN THAT ON
TWITTER, HE CALLED THE
PRESIDENT, QUOTE:  A WIMP
FOR MERELY SENDING THOUSANDS
OF TROOPS AND LAUNCHING TONS
OF BOMBS AT SYRIA.
THAT'S NOT ENOUGH FOR HOWARD
DEAN WHO YOU MAY REMEMBER
ONCE RAN FOR PRESIDENT AS
THE PEACE CANDIDATE.
TONIGHT HE WANTS TOTAL WAR
IN SYRIA.
TELEVISION PUNDITS, OF
COURSE, STRONGLY AGREE.
THIS MORNING THE FOREIGN
POLICY TEAM OVER ON MSNBC
EXEXPLAINED THAT IT'S FAR
MORE IMPORTANT FOR AMERICAN
TROOPS TO FIGHT IN SYRIA
THAN IT IS TO SECURE OUR OWN
BORDER HERE IN AMERICA U
WATCH.
>> THERE IS NO QUESTION THAT
NOW ALL THESE YEARS LATER IS
DONALD TRUMP'S CHALLENGE.
>> HE HAS TO TAKE ACTION.
HE HAS SPOKEN TO MACRON.
WHAT HE OUGHT TOO DO IS A
COORDINATED ACTION THERE HAS
TO BE A COORDINATED
RESPONSE.
>> AS TRUMP LEAVES TO FIGHT
HIS IMAGINARY BORDER WALL.
IS HE LEAVING THE REAL WAR
WHERE WE COULD MAKE A
DIFFERENCE AND TURNING IT
OVER TO ASSAD AND TO IRAN
AND TO ISIS.
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT
BARACK OBAMA WOULDN'T EVEN
DO IF CONFRONTED WITH THESE
SET OF FACTS.
>> Tucker: TRUMP HAS TO TAKE
ACTION IN SYRIA.
EVERYONE NODS SAGELY THAT
OUGHT TO MAKE YOU NERVOUS.
UNIVERSAL BIPARTISAN
AGREEMENT ON ANYTHING IS
USUALLY THE FIRST SIGN THAT
SOMETHING DEEPLY UNWISE IS
ABOUT TO HAPPEN.
IF ONLY BECAUSE THERE IS
NOBODY LEFT TO ASK SKEPTICAL
QUESTIONS.
AND WE SHOULD BE SKEPTICAL
OF THIS.
STARTING WITH THE POISON GAS
ATTACK ITSELF.
ALL THE GENIUSES TELL US
THAT ASSAD KILLED THOSE
CHILDREN, BUT DO THEY REALLY
KNOW THAT?
OF COURSE THEY DON'T REALLY
KNOW THAT THEY ARE MAKING IT
UP.
THEY HAVE NO REAL IDEA WHAT
HAPPENED.
ACTUALLY, BOTH SIDES IN THE
SYRIAN CIVIL WAR POSSESS
CHEMICAL WEAPONS.
HOW WOULD IT BENEFIT ASSAD
USING CHLORINE GAS LAST
WEEKEND?
WELL IT, WOULDN'T.
ASSAD'S FORCES HAVE BEEN
WINNING THE WAR IN SYRIA.
THE ADMINISTRATION JUST
ANNOUNCED ITS PLANS TO PULL
AMERICAN TROOPS OUT OF
SYRIA.
HAVING VANQUISHED ISIS.
THAT'S GOOD NEWS FOR ASSAD.
AND ABOUT THE ONLY THING HE
COULD DO TO REVERSE IT AND
HURT HIMSELF WOULD BE TO USE
POISON GAS AGAINST CHILDREN.
WELL, DID HE IT ANYWAY, THEY
TELL US.
IS HE THAT EVIL.
PLEASE.
KEEP IN MIND THIS IS THE
SAME STORY THEY TOLD US LAST
APRIL.
DO YOU REMEMBER THAT?
IT WAS ALMOST EXACTLY A YEAR
AGO.
THE NEW ADMINISTRATION
ANNOUNCED IT WAS NO LONGER
SEEKING TO DEPOSE ASSAD FROM
POWER.
REGIME CHANGE WAS NO LONGER
OUR POLICY.
THE USUAL WAR CHORUS IN
WASHINGTON STARTING YELPING
AND HE USED SARIN GAS.
THERE WAS VIDEO.
WE BOMBED A SYRIAN AIR BASE
IN RESPONSE TO THAT.
AT THE TIME THIS SHOW ASKED
THE OBVIOUS QUESTION ARE WE
REALLY SURE ASSAD DID THAT
SEEMS WEIRDLY TIMED AND
COUNTER PRODUCTIVE TO HIM.
SHUT UP, THEY EXPLAINED OF
COURSE WE ARE SURE.
WHAT AN UNPATRIOTIC
QUESTION.
BUT, OF COURSE, THEY WERE
LYING TWO.
MONTHS AGO THE SECRETARY OF
DEFENSE ADMITTED THAT
ACTUALLY WE STILL HAVE NO
PROOF THAT ASSAD USED
SAHARAN
USHARAN
USEARAN
USE SAN
USE SARINGAS.
PROPAGANDA.
MANIPULATE AMERICANS LIKE SO
MUCH OF WHAT THEY THEY SAY.
WE HAVE SEEN THIS MOVIE
BEFORE AND KNOW HOW IT ENDS.
FOR THE SAKE OF ARGUMENT,
LET'S ASSUME THEY ARE NOT
LYING THIS TIME.
LET'S ASSUME ASSAD DID JUST
USE SARIN GAS AGAINST KIDS.
IS HE PERFECTLY CAPABLE OF
THAT I'M NOT DEFENDING HIS
MORAL CHARACTER.
IF HE DID DO, IT WOULD THAT
BE WORTH STARTING A WAR
OVER.
CHAOS, MANY THOUSANDS WOULD
DIE.
IN FACT MIKE LIKELY SEE THE
GENOCIDE OF ONE OF THE LAST
REMAINING CHRISTIAN
COMMUNITIES IN THE MIDDLE
EAST AND WE OUGHT TO CARE
ABOUT THAT.
SOME OF THE DEAD, OF COURSE,
WOULD BE AMERICAN
SERVICEMEN.
A NEW WAR WOULD COST US TENS
OF BILLIONS OF DOLLARS.
MAYBE HUNDREDS OF BILLIONS.
WOULD IT MAKE AMERICA SAFER?
WOULD IT MAKE THE REGION
MORE STABLE?
LET'S SEE, HOW EXACTLY DID
REGIME CHANGE WORK IN IRAQ
AND LIBYA?
DOESN'T MATTER.
SAY OUR MORAL LEADERS ON CNN
AND EVERYWHERE ELSE.
ASTROS CITIES LIKE THIS
CANNOT BE TOLERATED.
OKAY.
BUT LET'S BE REAL, WE DO
TOLERATE ATROCITIES LIKE
THIS ALL THE TIME.
FOR EXAMPLE, THERE IS A
DEVASTATING FAMINE KILLING
CHILDREN IN YEMEN RIGHT NOW.
THE SAUDIS ARE CALLING THAT
FAMINE.
SHOULD WE DROP TAUM
SHOULD WE DROP TOMM
SHOULD WE DROP TOMAHAWKS ON
RIYADH NOT ACCORDING TO
YOUTUBE.
PICTURES ARE ESSENTIAL.
IN REAL LIFE, SYRIA IS A
HIGHLY COMPLICATED PLACE.
WITH ASSAD GONE.
WHO WOULD RUN IT EXACTLY?
DO WE HAVE ANOTHER STRONG
MAN IN PLACE TO INSTALL?
OR IS IT OUR HOPE THAT HE A
STABLE DEMOCRACY WILL
MAGICALLY APPEAR IN THE WAKE
OF THIS PROTRACTED CIVIL
AREA?
WHO EXACTLY ARE THESE
MODERATE REBELS YOU HEAR
ABOUT.
THE ONES WE ARE SUPPORTING
WITH YOUR TAX DOLLARS?
A LOT OF THEM TURN OUT TO BE
ISLAMIST CRAZIES.
THE CITY WITH A CHEMICAL
ATTACK JUST OCCURRED IS
MOSTLY CONTROLLED BY THE
ARMY OF ISLAM.
RADICAL GROUP CALLED FOR
ESTABLISHING AN ISLAMIC
STATE UNDER SHARIA LAW IN
SYRIA.
THAT GROUP'S FOUNDER CALLED
FOR EXTERMINATING ALL SHE A
MUSLIMS AND ALOE WHITES FROM
THE COUNTRY.
WE ARE SUPPOSED TO WAGE A
NEW WAR ON THIS GROUP'S
BEHALF.
WHY IS THAT EXACTLY?
BACK IN 2013, WHEN THE
SYRIAN CIVIL WAR WAS STILL
IN ITS EARLY DAYS, ONE
ONLOOKER WEIGHED IN ON
TWITTER.
HERE IS PART OF WHAT HE
WROTE.
QUOTE:  WE SHOULD STAY THE
HELL OUT OF SYRIA.
THE REBELS ARE JUST AS BAD
AS THE CURRENT REGIME.
WHAT WILL WE GET FOR OUR
LIVES AND BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS?
ZERO.
IN ANOTHER TWEET HE SAID,
THIS QUOTE:  LET THE ARAB
LEAGUE TAKE CARE OF SYRIA.
WHY RICH ARAB COUNTRIES NOT
PAYING FOR SUCH A TREMENDOUS
COST OF SUCH AN ATTACK.
ANOTHER TWEET HE SAID.
THIS WHAT WILL WE GET FOR
BOMBING SYRIA INBESIDES MORE
DEBT AND CONFLICT.
, YOU KNOW WHO WROTE THAT
DONALD TRUMP.
HE WAS WRITE RIGHT.
THAT'S ONE OF THE REASONS HE
GOT ELECTED PRESIDENT.
NOW THE SAME PEOPLE WHO
BROUGHT YOU A DYING AMERICAN
MIDDLE CLASS, UNDEFENDED
AMERICAN BORDERS, AND
ENDLESS POINTLESS WARS IN
COUNTRIES YOU COULD NOT FIND
ON A MAP ARE TELLING THE
PRESIDENT HE HAS GOT TO
DEPOSE ASSAD FOR REASONS
THAT ARE BOTH UNCLEAR AND
DEMONSTRABLY DISHONEST.
BY THE WAY, IT MAY HAPPEN.
BUT, BEFORE IT DOES,
CONGRESS OUGHT TO CONSIDER A
BRAND NEW CONSTITUTIONAL
AMENDMENT.
LET'S CALL IT THE LINDSEY
GRAHAM AMENDMENT.
AND HERE'S WHAT IT WOULD
SAY.
CONGRESS SHALL TOPPLE NO
GOVERNMENT UNTIL IT FINISHES
REBUILDING THE LAST
GOVERNMENT IT TOPPLED.
AND FURTHERMORE, TALK SHOW
GENERALS SHALL BE REQUIRED
TO PERSONALLY VISIT THE
BATTLEFIELD OF EVERY WAR
THEY ADVOCATE FOR.
END OF AMENDMENT.
THAT WOULD HAVE AN IMMEDIATE